- I feel like at this point
with these taste tests,
every time someone tells
me ti's a mystery meat,
I'm expecting like balls.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- It's possible I've never
had Haitian food before.
- I don't really know what
it's going to taste like.
Maybe tropical?
Caribbean? (laughs)
- I am a Haitian virgin, right? (laughs)
(upbeat instrumental music)
- Look how cute this is.
- Oh my god.
- That's really good.
- Sign me up, gimme all of that.
Yes.
- Greasy.
- [Man] It's very smoky.
- It's awesome.
- [Woman in blue] With like
some spiced meat goin' on, but not spicy.
It's just great, it's flavorful.
- That's a money shot right there.
- How could you not like this?
It's just puff pastry and meat.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- That is not what I
expected from goat meat.
- I feel like I can
taste what it last ate.
I'm not okay with that.
- If you have goat cheese with it,
is that like sick and wrong?
- This is tender.
And it is flavorful.
- Goat is my new favorite meat.
(upbeat music)
- It's juicy.
Is it fried?
- Anything fried is great.
- Look how tender this is.
It's so tender.
- I could eat this every
day and just be like fine.
- I'm sorry, Mom, but I wish
you could cook like this.
(laughs) I really do.
(upbeat music)
- Oh, that smells so good!
- And it's not really fishy.
- Yeah, like it's not
too chewy either though.
- Very well seasoned, very well spiced.
I'm a big fan.
- Couldn't taste the conch though.
Just ate the whole thing at once.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- There's the spine!
(whines) Oh my god.
- This is how a fish should
be prepared, you know.
We shouldn't like take all
of the (beep) out of it.
- I mean the bones are like
easy enough to pick out,
if a little inconvenient.
- You get stabbed with a bone once,
you don't get stabbed with a bone twice.
- I'm a carnivore.
I feel like a (beep) predator.
- Oh, ugh.
I thought there was no bones,
and there was one in there.
- There's not a whole lot done to the fish
in terms of seasoning.
It's good.
- (kissing smacks) Thank you.
- Thank you for that.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- So many flavors.
- It's like it's banana
bread but covered in sugar.
- I don't like the word moist, but like,
this is like a good moist.
- [Girl in Vest] It's moist.
You can hear the--
(chewing smacks)
- I got the clean plate award though.
Mmhmm.
(upbeat music)
- I like Haitian food.
- I didn't know that there's
this amazing, delicious
flavor profile just waiting for me.
- It's very rare that you
go through a taste test,
and you think everything
is awesome, but seriously.
- [Together] Everything is awesome!
- It was so good!
- [Girl in blue] It was great!
- Take me to Haiti now!
- [Girl in hat] Yes.
- This is amazing!
I want all of it.
- [Girl in hat] I do too.
- Because it's what everybody loves.
- Now it's time to take a nap.
(claps) Woo!
- I have a huge mouth
and very low standards
in terms of how I look on camera. (laughs)